many experts say the president may need
to carry pennsylvania to secure a second
term
he won by less than one percentage point
there back in 2016.
now the latest cbs news battleground
tracker poll shows
president trump trailing former vice
president biden by seven points in
pennsylvania
but there is still a feeling that this
race may be tightening in the remaining
hours
that's like right now jerika duncan is
at a polling place
in philadelphia county jericho good
morning to you what do you see
good morning a number of people as you
can see behind me waiting for their
chance to cast their ballot
first person we spoke to in this line
that entered about 15 minutes ago said
they got here
at 5 45 this morning this is an area no
doubt in pennsylvania where both
campaigns are hoping to increase
the african-american turnout when you
look back in 2016
that turnout was about seven points
lower than expected
for hillary clinton the trump campaign
has been running ads across the country
trying to garner black male support
pointing to things like the president's
criminal justice reform efforts
i spoke to pastor alan waller who leads
a philadelphia's largest one of
philadelphia's largest baptist
churches he believes it was necessary to
publicly support a candidate
and it's support that could influence
his nearly 12 thousand members
there's absolutely nothing wrong with me
standing you
here and telling you what i'm hoping for
and that is that joe biden
will win this and that we will clean up
our government
and pastor waller's church enoch
tabernacle baptist church is actually
going to be
a polling place for the first time and
that was due to coven
anthony jerica thank you